no I don't do a lot of love scenes
anymore no that's a shame by the way you
should because you always smell good the
last time you were here you had this
amazing Cologne and you spritzed it on
me cuz I kept complimenting how good you
smell I really was very fruity and
annoying and I sprayed it on me and then
you left your cologne bottle here and I
stole it you're lucky
well I be who had left you left and I
just took it was like you're appropriate
there was only like two drops left it
was not much he was like literally
almost done and they came back and asked
the next day for it I'm sorry it's gone
you're lucky though because I feel like
depending on the interview I guess in
that interview you guys were talking
about good smells I've seen other
interviews with you where flatulence is
a big part of it that's what I say yes
yes it is I mean I started out there to
demonstrate it and then saw Carly
standing right beside me and restrained
myself but yes yes I am an excellent
forger
why are you really for it I didn't know
that yes
how are you famous for it gasser that
was incredible yes that was like you
shouldn't have I would have done it to
the microphone but if you look at my
position that would have been a teenage
man what are you doing you're too late
you're too late there's only there was
one in the chamber in the dance of
Toronto when did you realize that I
guess you know I always get upset like
for instance actors who are also singers
I go you shouldn't be able to do both
well because for somebody like me who
just needs to be tell wishes he was
talented at something I go how could you
have both these talents for you to be
able to be this phenomenal actor and
then also be able to do that [ __ ] you
you know in fair James Joyce yes it was
married to Nora Barnacle and she always
thought he should be a singer and he was
in fact a pretty good writer maybe the
best in the 20th century he was doing a
an interview at the end of his life he
was blind and they were talking about
Finnegan's Wake and Ulysses and I guess
probably portrait of an artist as a
young man
and the interview was for an
intellectual journal it went on for
three days in the middle of the third
day the interviewer said I would like to
speak with you about your personal life
you know you're blind no your wife Nora
Barnacle has been with you your entire
life
she's been your your wife your lover the
mother of your children your muse your
editor and now here she is your eyes
what do you have to say about that
relationship and Joyce thought for a
moment and then he said I would know my
wife's fart in a hole but I mean can you
imagine anything more perfectly defining
yeah relationship that's our intimacy
yeah yeah yeah but but but I can I tell
you something yours I don't know I smell
show no no what I got ready for it can
you fly again I fill my trousers with
Cologne yeah negative there's no order
at all it's amazing I don't want to
counteract the other but the audible the
audible quality is really good yeah I
also carry enjoyment u-87 what is that
that's Michael yeah it's the best it
really is the best obviously uh the guy
I got the talent for that from my mother
she could fart on command she didn't
have to because she learned it all the
time she was a a crop duster every step
she took yeah is this something she was
doing for fun to amuse you or just to
get it all out of her no she was she was
walking trying to get away from them
now what now were you embarrassed by
this Russia embarrassed by this or did
she not care no I just always kept ahead
of her what a great gift yeah what it
what it what an amazing an amazing
talent that is but so you don't have you
have a reputation for being an excellent
farter but for the for and not to be the
Oder not to be bad because like no no
actually that's not true
oh there's a there's a continuity woman
who was sitting bless her heart sitting
down by the camera and I had to walk
through through to pass by the camera
sure and the camera was just going to
see me from the waist down
mm-hm and she had her head beside the
camera and as I started my walk I
started to fart as I passed the camera
she screamed film it's a big-budget
thing where you can't just stop and
start you know beg your fart has to be
for a camera operator to blow the day
know there was a continuity woman of all
people the blow to take the continuity
yet even the camera camera and she
screamed because it was so odorous my
god yeah misogyny like our thing abou
she could be talking about the election